buongiorno ignorate la cravatta me ne
sto prendendo sempre di più questa
mattina potevo farne a meno
mi chiamo umberto nicolini sono un
architetto urbanista grazie per essere
qua in un sabato di pioggia in cambio
faccio voto di non annoiarvi con troppi
tecnicismi abbandono la mia coperta di
linus e quindi magari modifica un po
quello che probabilmente di dire dunque
io sono un architetto sono un architetto
quindi mi occupo di oggetti nel mio
lavoro mi occupo di oggetti di diverse
scale siano essi oggetti di design fino
arrivare alle città mi occupo di persone
mi occupo di persone perché i fatti
umani si svolgono dentro lo spazio che
viene progettato
cominciamo male mi direte voi un pò di
banalità per cominciare
ecco davanti a questa affermazione così
banale
e così vera lo spazio del contenuto dei
fatti umani abbiamo tradizionalmente ha
avuto due risposte due tipi di risposte
in passato una che arriva per lo più da
chi si occupa della società dal punto di
vista umano quella di sottovalutare
l'influenza dello spazio all'interno del
come causa degli eventi o come concausa
un'altra quella degli architetti dei
cari colleghi
ecco questo primo approccio ormai
possiamo divertire stato abbandonato
buona parte l'atteggiamento dei cari
colleghi e quello invece di essere
formati tutt'oggi purtroppo come dei
demiurghi l'architetto viene cresciuto
per lo più nella convinzione che il suo
intervento determini fatti umani
quindi lo spazio non è un contenuto
semplicemente c'è un contenitore scusate
ma è l'unico oggetto che determina
l'esistenza delle persone con la
conseguenza del l'idea che la bellezza
risolva i problemi la bellezza formale
ecco dopo questa introduzione polemica
che prima o poi mi farà cacciare
dall'ordine passo a illustrarvi perché
sono qua oggi sotto mandato io questa
mattina per fare per iniziare con un
esempio prendendo le 91 alle 21 al
filobus pc che fa la circonvallazione di
milano gira quasi tutta la notte a una
pausa di un paio d'ore e sulla 91 si
possono si può assistere episodi
interessantissimi che all'occasione e
all'interesse può venire a milano fare
un giro notturno di due tre ore sulla 91
e per assistere a qualunque tipo di
avvenimento in una quota vengono città
questa mattina ho preso davanti alle sei
e mezza e come sempre come conosco metà
del filobus è occupato da persone che
due fermate prima arrivavano da
all'ortomercato di milano soprattutto
asiatici con degli enormi pacchi di
verdure raccolti all'ortomercato
comprato la tua casa per poi andrà
essere distribuiti nei vari ristoranti
etnici unica altra persona oltre a
questi signori ea me guidatore
ovviamente una signora anziana
appena sono salito si è dovuto a sedere
a fianco una retta
meno male non ve lo dico milanese perché
fare un giorno disastro
meno male che è arrivato anche lei ero
qua tutto spaventata ora non ho fatto
una fotografia perché non ci ho pensato
ho passato dopo episodio però immaginate
5 6 7 8 10 pakistan i cinesi hanno
contatti concreti dalle trevano
l'ortomercato raccogliere le offerte
migliori
con questi nomi sacchi di verdura anche
motore di da mercato delle erbe
fantastico quale minaccia possono
rappresentare per
signora dopo una signora anziana signora
terrorizzata
ora questo è un tipico esempio di un
conflitto chiuso entrambe le popolazioni
vogliamo definirle così ritengono con
l'uso del mezzo pubblico perfettamente
normale per loro però per la signora
questo è un problema
questo avviene in un luogo ben
determinato quindi in alto luoghi se
questi fossero stati per strada quando i
sacchi di verdura questo non sarebbe
accaduto
la stessa mia posizione qua oggi io non
sapevo cosa aspettarmi
temevo la cattedra
detesto questo è già un tipo di rapporto
diverso e lo spazio non è cambiato il
modo in cui lo stiamo utilizzando
diverso se io non fossi qua al centro e
vi chiedessi girare tutte le sedie un
rapporto più interattivo lo stesso
spazio avrebbe un'altra valenza quindi
l'influenza dello spazio su quello che
facciamo è importante ma non
determinante quindi progetto in questo
bellissimo spazio non è così fuente con
l'influenza di come lo si usa perché la
sicurezza perché credo che più o meno
quei tutti o premiate nel campo del
sociale della convivenza della
multiculturalità e credo che come me
sciopero non altro punto di vista siate
in stufi di sentire regolarmente
l'accoppiata convivenza sicurezza sempre
in termini negativi ovviamente mai con
ormai salvo quando si va a lavorare tra
di noi
maicon la valenza di convivenza uguale
più sicurezza
io ringrazio moltissimo le banche e la
finanza che quest'anno ci hanno
risparmiato una campagna elettorale
basata sui problemi di sicurezza legati
alla convivenza ricordatevi quelle
precedenti quindi noi come architetti
siamo specializzati su quello che
l'impatto sulla sicurezza
della forma urbana si va per cui quando
l'assessore corradini mi ha coinvolta in
questo bellissimo progetto ho cercato di
mi sono domandato quali siano le
implicazioni quale sia il rapporto tra
la sicurezza dello spazio e la
convivenza sicuramente c'è una ricaduta
della sicurezza degli spazi sulla
convivenza perché perché uno spazio
sicuro un luogo sicuro ha determinate
caratteristiche e più utilizzato prima e
più banale più scontata c'è più senso di
appropriazione in un luogo sicuro le
persone si sentono parte di quel luogo
il centro di possederlo c'è più vitalità
ovviamente le obiezioni sono sempre
possibili quindi se qualcuno vuole
intervenire non c'è problema c'è più
condivisione
riassumendo possiamo dire che un luogo
sicuro facilita la convivenza d'altra
parte ci domandiamo quali siano i
risvolti di una buona convivenza tra le
persone tra le culture sulla sicurezza
il rapporto biunivoco quindi quindi dove
c'è convivenza dove la convivenza
funziona ed è positiva c'è più mix
sociale culturale economico c'è più
vitalità la vitalità è una questione
fondamentale per potere teoria della
sicurezza c'è più rispetto non solo
delle persone ma anche dei luoghi che
l'utility che queste persone utilizzano
e c'è più libertà in uno spazio dove c'è
convivenza in un luogo dove c'è
convivenza c'è più sicurezza
siccome io opero sulla sicurezza
forzatamente e volentieri molto spesso
mi trovo a lavorare con i temi della
condanna
ti darò un brevissimo accenno sul che
cosa vuol dire sicurezza oggi allora
prima vorrei comprare non ho fatto la
premessa sgombro ogni dubbio parliamo di
sicurezza personale attento questo tipo
di pubblico non penso di dover
specificare perché molto spesso dopo che
pago di sicurezza mi vengono a
contattare i pompieri piuttosto che
ingegneria strutturale
parliamo di sicurezza delle persone
allora oggi come oggi quando si parla di
sicurezza il termine improprio
parliamo di paura parliamo di paura che
è un'estensione è una specie migliore
specificazione del problema
la paura fino a un po di anni fa aveva
una definizione molto semplice che
corrisponde alla prima che leggete il
rischio concreto di rimanere vittima di
un'aggressione o episodi di violenza in
passato si semplifica va dicendo
la gente ha paura perché ha paura di
essere aggredita violentata e rapinata
ora anni di studi
sapevo che non siano troppo banali
queste cose va cercato di semplificare
hanno portato alla definizione della
paura legata al territorio che è molto
più estesa in particolare un aspetto
importantissimo è la rottura dei codici
tradizionali il comportamento che cosa
vuol dire questo è un filone che adesso
ad esempio nel mondo che lo stato è
preponderante quello che loro chiamano
anti social behaviour ma può essere
esteso anche a quello che dicevo prima
del filobus 3a la presenza di diverse
culture che hanno tradizionalmente un
uso dello spazio diverso non sempre non
sempre riescono a rendere compatibile
tra di loro e l'uso degli spazi quindi
si va da atteggiamenti che sono fuori
dal normale comportamento per qualunque
cultura e che non sono però per
riconosciuti
spesso come non sono reati non sono
crimini non sono giustamente
perseguibili e come l'impatto che hanno
sulla percezione delle persone è
devastante
possiamo anche identificarne alcuni ecco
la mancanza di cura del territorio qui
entriamo più nell'aspetto della gestione
dello spazio nella gestione delle
architetture se ancora vi abbiamo fatto
alcuni esempi in questo la manutenzione
dello spazio pubblico la pulizia dello
spazio pubblico il funzionamento delle
cose le fermate dell'autobus conoscono
vandalizzate hanno una ricaduta enorme
sulle persone c'è una zona di milano
nella zona di via padova
forse avrete sentito per qualche cronaca
è passato che i giornali additano come
la peggior zona di milano la gente
terrorizzata via padova una zona di
fatto centrale piazzale loreto con anche
delle case di pregio
con una forte componente multietnica che
ha avuto qualche passato qualche
problema troppo di relazione tra diverse
comunità di immigrati e dove il tasso di
criminalità tutto sommato è decisamente
basso se guardiamo non solo la
criminalità ufficiale cioè quella
riportata la polizia ma è quella
attraverso altre indagini riusciamo a
identificare la gente è terrorizzata
perché attraverso le interviste
scopriamo che la signora perché ha paura
paura e la violenza una donna più dense
di attività di milano no no perché
l'altra sera sono scesa e c'era uno che
faceva pipì sono più suo fianco la mia
casa
ecco questo è un problema legato all'uso
uno spazio urbano e alla mano e alla
gestione lo spazio urbano che è tra le
principali cause dell'insicurezza che
abbiamo le nostre città oggi non importa
se due palazzi a fianco viene scoperto e
arrestato il grande trafficante d'armi
alla signora anziana milanese fa più
impressione vedere magari la banda di
ragazzotti che vede fanno casino in
maniera assolutamente legale e magari
soltanto un po rumorosa la sensazione di
sicurezza disgiunta dalla sicurezza
reale quindi dovuta allo squallore dello
spazio urbano alla mancanza di vitalità
e qui purtroppo dobbiamo dire che la
progettazione e soprattutto
l'urbanistica negli ultimi decenni ci
sono molto concentrate sugli aspetti
formali ignorando molto spesso quali
fossero poi gli eventi che potevano
accadere negli spazi che progettava e
quindi quanti di voi hanno in mente
quella che chiamo cattedrali nel deserto
grandi piazze dove non succede niente
dove
vengono prese d'assalto dai vandali o
addirittura migliorate anche dai vandali
quando in una camminata diciamo che
quando in una piazza non ci sono nemmeno
i graffiti vuol dire che poco è
sbagliata completamente e la paura
intesa come sentimento soggettivo li
rientra nelle individualità delle
persone le persone hanno paura perché
ognuno a modo più comodo proprio c'è chi
rimane terrorizzata da qualche giorno fa
qualche settimana fa sembrava che
improvvisamente in tutta l'india
le donne sono violentate come se fosse
la novità è che abbiamo non so se avete
visto dovuto due settimane in cui ogni
giorno di pour ce li portavano quanti
stop e divenire
ecco questo è un po di influenza anche i
media che si concentrano seminate
notizia che è sorto alcune categorie di
persone hanno un impatto molto forte
davanti a questa evoluzione del concetto
di paura c'è stata un'evoluzione del
concetto della risposta all insicurezza
qui sarò sintetico allora la risposta ai
problemi in sicurezza
oggi come oggi si articola secondo tre
filoni principali quello istituzionale
ha detto anche loro in dr
la polizia attenzione la polizia che si
è evoluta non è più semplicemente la
repressione del fatto avvenuto
la polizia e moltissimi casi italia
siamo molto avanti su questo si è
specializzata anche un diverso rapporto
con la cittadinanza in processi di
dialogo di comunicazione e prevenzione
del crimine per prevenzione è la parola
che sta davanti a tutto il concetto di
approccio di sicurezza un approccio di
tipo sociale quindi che va a intervenire
sulle cause umane del disagio quindi
dell'insicurezza e più recente un
approccio di tipo ambientale quindi
legato al luogo
io vi parlerò di sopra la mente di cos'è
l'approccio ambientale in quanto sono un
architetto non sono un sociologo e un
poliziotto
allora l'approccio ambientale nasce da
una rivoluzione
devo tagliare tutto però preferisco
resiste analisi da una rivoluzione nelle
teorie peppino logiche che
tradizionalmente studiavano il crimine
come un risultato di una interazione tra
un aggressore una vittima e con un
processo che oggi sembra sembra banale
detto così sembra cioè poteva arrivarci
anch'io più tutti potevano arrivarci ci
sono voluti 50 anni ancora non è
accettato
un'evoluzione che vede i pimi ne
parliamo di crimine ma in realtà
parliamo in generale di insicurezza come
un interazione tra un aggressore o un
potenziale aggressore una vittima una
potenziale vittima e un contesto quindi
il riconoscimento dell'importanza del
luogo in cui sicurezza si genera come
uno degli attori che partecipano a
questo processo
l'assioma su cui il nostro lavoro si
basa è che l'open edizione
l'organizzazione dello spazio e della
città influisce sulla sicurezza dei
luoghi può contribuire a renderli molto
cicu più sicuri ma può anche essere
determinante nel renderli meno sicuri
questo perché organizza strutturare bene
uno spazio uno spazio o intanto
aumentare quello che viene indetta
sorveglianza spontanea da parte dei
cittadini
la sorveglianza spontanea un concetto
nato dalle delle teorie degli uteri tipi
di jane jacobs el economista entro polo
che americana che negli anni sessanta
scrive un libro bellissimo che consiglio
chi non lo conosca già che evita è morta
delle grandi città americane nel quale
da un'accelerazione alla città con un
taglio completamente diverso a quanto
fatto finora crea un senso di
appartenenza rispetto al territorio
allora le persone che vivono in un
territorio di cui si sentono padroni tra
virgolette e quindi i responsabili se ne
prendono cura
si sentono più sicuri sono più
confidence in questo territorio
questo cosa vuol dire che il territorio
dp dentemente dalla sua buona o cattiva
proprietà zione indipendentemente dalla
sua bellezza che è soggettiva
è più adatto ad ospitare le persone
anche e soprattutto le persone che in
quel territorio che in quello spazio
arrivano casualmente e non sono
familiari poco spazio
questo importantissimo ad esempio nei
nodi di traffico di vite scambio in quei
luoghi dove la maggior parte degli
utenti sono in una co presenza non
convivenza e ci rimangono per poco non
ho tempo di capire che tipo di gioco sia
allora un nuovo ben tenuto genera nelle
persone un meccanismo quasi non
cosciente di questo tipo se qui c'è
qualcuno che si prende cura di questo
spazio
vuol dire che si prenderà cura anche di
me qualora avesse bisogno
questo è il processo che si genera una
teoria ogni tanto che sui giornali con
il nome di teoria delle finestre rotte e
quindi una buona organizzazione dello
spazio contribuisce a diminuire la
sensazione di insicurezza e di paura
facilità anche il lavoro delle forze
dell'ordine questo è uno strumento che
usiamo per convincere poi gli enti
polizia collaborare con noi nella
progettazione
io vi risparmierete o una lunga serie di
principi fondamentali e saltiamo perché
mancano 20 secondi quindi mi basta
raccontarvi che davanti dopo questo
apparato disciplinare teorico tutto
sommato semplice ma che ha impiegato
appunto 50 anni per svilupparsi sono
stati si sono calati anche gli strumenti
operativi
esistono oggi delle tecniche sia per
rilevare la potenziale di sicurezza o di
insicurezza gli spazi a partire dalle
loro caratteristiche fisiche quindi si
possono dare degli indicatori e poi
portano a dare una valutazione di quanto
uno spazio possa o meno essere sicuro
sia esistono delle normative esiste una
normativa europea che indica dei
principi guida su come
costruire e progettare uno spazio
tenendo conto di quello che all'interno
di questo spazio avviene in un'ottica di
sicurezza e quindi ritengo anche come
uno stretto legame per quanto riguarda
la convivenza grazie